yes i told her you loved her
no i will not give her a big kiss for
you
fine i will give her a big kiss for you
i love this show that is gina yasharay
from the hit cbs comedy bob hearts
abishola have you seen it gotta check it
out yasharay is an english actor she's a
producer and she is a stand-up comic did
you know that she's also the daughter of
nigerian parents and a proud member of
the lgbtq community so we asked her to
tell us what pride means to her
it's june and that means it's pride
month
it's not a history month
or an awareness month
pride
truth is
we shouldn't need it
we shouldn't need months where we
celebrate facets of simply being human
we have it because a dominant group of
people have decided what is normal and
acceptable and have forced their fake
ideals on us for so long that it's
become the fabric of society and that is
very hard to unravel
yet pride is a fitting word because it's
an antidote to shame
many queer people and i include myself
have spent a chunk of our lives hiding
who we are because of shame and the fear
of repercussions of living our true
selves that could mean losing our
families our jobs our social networks
and being subjected to violence and
harassment and then i decided i wanted
to become a comedian
and i thought well she ain't gonna like
that i might as well come out to her and
go for the double whammy
my mom was like what what are you
telling me you are telling me
that my daughter
is a gay clown
for me the first attraction i felt for
another woman was around the age of 12
it was my biology teacher
i misbehaved in class just to get her
attention and let me tell you it felt
good when i got it even if that
attention was her kicking me out of
class
i didn't know how to define it then
later when i fully recognized that i was
attracted to women i was terrified that
there was something wrong with me
my mother had no idea which i couldn't
understand because i practically came
out of the womb wearing a tool belt but
she kept calling me when are you going
to get married when are you going to
give me grandchildren whereas my friends
were just biding their time waiting for
me to tell them what they knew already
my brothers who i'm extremely close to
were totally unbothered one of them had
a friend who was a lesbian and she'd
seen me at various gay clubs around
london and she'd already ratted me out
when the world is awash in rainbows it
feels wonderful for our visibility a
symbol of how far we've come
in some ways it's become a big
commercial party which is not
necessarily a bad thing as it means
we're getting closer to acceptance once
the big corporations see that rainbows
can look a lot like dollar signs with a
little imagination but it's also
bittersweet we still have a long way to
go
black trans women who were at the
forefront of the stonewall uprising the
event that launched the gay rights
movement have been whitewashed from
history today they are still far more
likely to be either incarcerated or
murdered than any other group
[Music]
pride means showing up
pride means being your true self loudly
and without shame pride is another form
of resistance
pride says to someone who may be
struggling with their identity look at
me
and look at the sheer number of people
who are like you
pride means you're not alone
and there is nothing wrong with you
she's good she had so many funny lines i
think comedians can't help themselves
that she came out with a tool belt that
when she told her mom she said her mom
said what am i what do i have here a gay
clown very very nicely done yeah i love
it gina pride does mean nothing's wrong
with you i love that yeah i love the way
she ended it that's a great essay one of
my favorites and that you shouldn't need
months to celebrate being human i really
like that best of all also want to give
a shout out to andy murli i said who did
this piece in because i say this all the
time viewers who are watching us it is
so hard to do a piece where there's no
reporter track where you just take the
visuals and you take the audio and you
take the music and you put it together
so special shout out to andy merliss
they said it's andy merliss special
brian mcinerney special shout out to you
for editing editing is very important
and the photographer one of my favorite
people in this building kenton young
that's right i love me some kenyan
that's right nicely done team nicely